the desperation written on tiny faces
[Music]
please to be allowed to leave the chaos
of kabul
but men women and so many children
without the right paperwork were turned
away
at the same time in late august emails
and letters were being sent back and
forth across government trying to secure
evacuation for animals and staff of the
nazad charity
despite growing evidence on a trip to
wales today boris johnson insists he
wasn't involved this whole thing is is
is total rhubarb uh i i
was very proud of what
our armed services did the military
always prioritized
human
beings and that was quite right
the pm pointing out the military didn't
prioritize animals for departure but
critics claim that others did by working
to get one group of animals the
clearance and the means to leave
a lot revolves around the involvement of
trudy harrison one of the prime
minister's aides and the priorities she
gave to trying to secure special flights
sky news can reveal emails between
virgin atlantic staff after a phone call
from trudy harrison
one email stated that relevant
permissions to leave kabul would be
fast-tracked in government while another
said that this was a government-backed
situation and incredibly sensitive
and it's that phrase government-backed
that has got critics wondering how
involved downing street really was
why was trudy harrison so confident that
if a plane could be found she could get
those permissions rushed through
and why on around the same date the 25th
of august did others including the
foreign office seem to believe that the
prime minister himself had personally
intervened
at the end of the day this isn't just
about animals it's about who took
priority in an impossible situation and
why
trudy harrison says she was acting as a
constituency mp but questions are now
being asked across the house of commons
everybody knows i'm animal lover but i
also love people as well
and what i would say is i think there's
a story to come out but it's not for me
to judge today
others though have already made up their
minds well somebody is lying about what
happened during the events that led up
to the evacuation of the the animals
from afghanistan and i think it's become
increasingly clear that the prime
minister's story is not credible he has
not told the truth
for those left behind an argument over
emails means very little now but as
boris johnson faces questions on all
sides about his leadership what happened
late last year is in sharper focus than
ever
kate mccann sky news